22 million americans lost their jobs  when the pandemic hit about  half are back at work but millions are  still struggling to find a job  and according to a new linkedin survey  many of them believe that being  unemployed is hurting their chances  about 67 percent of them to be exact 84  believe there's a stigma surrounding  unemployment but  the vast majority of hiring managers  want to get the word out they say they  would hire someone laid off because of  this pandemic  and that applicants may even be unaware  that they have certain skills that can  apply to  many other industries one of my favorite  examples  is of these transferable skills is i  talked to an insurance company at one  point they said that when they are  trying to hire insurance adjusters they  try to hire bartenders because  bartenders have a skill of getting  people to tell stories  the linkedin survey also found 46  percent of unemployed americans lied  about being out of work